et ce soir c'est moi qui vais jouer avec
samuel etienne botton dosage je sais pas
il a préparé quatre thèmes pour moi je
vous dis punk à jouer on jouera à
question 1,4 à la suisse est issu savoir
et c'est ma passion
rien que ça fait très longtemps je vais
pas fait j'étais au bout du rouleau
sachez le
j'ai vécu des moments très difficiles
est visible via très difficile de ne
plus le faire
elle doit durer quatre à la suite on a
fini à 4 heures du matin qu'est-ce qui
se passe naji le vrai qu'après la suite
on aurait fini à 4 heures du mat une
ceinture comme vous n'êtes pas très très
cultivé la charité non non mais c'est
vrai que alors là attention côté nantes
on a fait mouche non mais moi je veux
bien
non mais c'est vrai je veux bien ouais
mais alors je vous le dis franchement
mathieu 25 jan
non pas du tout vous avez tout à fait le
droit de dire ce que vous pensez ouais
vous trouvez que je ne suis pas cultiver
à ce que je vous dis aussi quand on a
fait ce pas si la chanteuse en france 3
arrive dans ce qu'on peut
jouyet a noté way et quand on va arrêter
son émission le vendredi sur ces mineurs
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est vrai elle sera peu près tout ce
qui se passe un coup de pression quoi
venez faire un coup de pression il vous
reste et fait montre alors c'est
peut-être un truc que j'ai a prêté un
diamant ça je te montrer mais là vient
la télé plus facile à chanter
vraiment le faire sur moi non ouais tu
aimes pas s'effondrer à tout tout bête
chauffer hockey n'est fait pas mal série
non mais ça a pris là en ce moment dans
mes cours est d'accord néanmois draft
non non non ça s'appelle à ew com
comment magique c'est prêt c'est un truc
tout bête tu fais ça t'amène à personne
à côté du centre et du coup écoute
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
parce que là
à la foire et web très bien l'asie
un petit tour de ma cousine hier je ne
suis pas votre cousine mercier